[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde les profiteurs de la fric de
quoi s'agit-il
l'Afrique participe de la mondialisation
au même titre que les autres continents
elle ne manque pas d'atouts pour être un
aiguillon du progrès et du développement
une démographie vigoureuse et jeune des
richesses minières et énergétiques une
classe moyenne qui consomme une
croissance soutenue mais elle n'en
profite pas la mesure de ces richesses
pour des raisons à la fois intérieures
ce continent et sans cesse précarisé par
des conflits violents le terrorisme et
une corruption endémique mais aussi et
surtout selon la majorité des
observateurs africains voire
occidentaux parce que ce continent n'est
pas protagoniste de son destin selon le
pape François au cours d'un récent des
plans déplacement pardon en République
démocratique du Congo l'Afrique subirait
toujours les effets délétères et je le
cite d'un colonialisme économique
déchaîné sont un criminés pêle-mêle les
drastiques ajustements structurels du
FMI de la Banque mondiale de l'OMC les
pressions de la Chine de la Russie de
l'Europe le pillage des ressources le
soutien des dictateurs l'ingérence dans
les affaires intérieures bref l'Afrique
cherche à conquérir une légitime
souveraineté pour agir face aux enjeux
économiques sociaux climatiques et
stratégique qui agissent la planète pour
en parler discerner qui sont ces
profiteurs de l'Afrique nous le ferons
avec mes invités que je vous présente
alors nous avons madame Aminata Dramane
Traoré qui est en visioconférence depuis
le Mali je rappelle madame Traoré vous
êtes ancienne ministre de la Culture et
du Tourisme du Mali et vous êtes
également essayiste Sylvie Brunel vous
êtes professeur des universités Calix
Beyala vous êtes romancière et Antoine
Glaser qui est journaliste et essayiste
[Musique]
vous venez de voir cette citation du
pape François qui dit cesser d'étouffer
l'Afrique elle n'est pas une mine à
exploiter et une terre à dévaliser alors
d'après les statistiques et autres
projections tant international africaine
l'Afrique connaît un développement
certain et des avancées conséquentes de
l'espérance de vie aux autres
indicateurs du développement humain
qu'il s'agisse de la santé de
l'éducation du niveau de vie alors
pourquoi cette image persistante de
prédation de pillage des ressources de
corruption croissante bref de mal
développé
écoutez je tenais d'abord à saluer
Aminata vraiment mais vraiment salut
c'est Stone cela est dû essentiellement
d'abord à l'histoire à l'histoire de
l'esclavage à l'histoire coloniale aussi
quand un peuple a été pendant des
siècles aussi
maltraités méprisé écrasé étouffé
n'oubliez pas surtout que durant ces
périodes tous les hommes brillants ont
été systématiquement soit déportés soit
assassiné donc l'Afrique s'est retrouvée
un moment donné très démunie tous les
quoi mekuma sont retrouvés morts en exil
les union B tous ces hommes qui
portaient l'Afrique en réalité parce que
vous savez toutes les sociétés ont
besoin des figures fortes pour avancer
ont été tous décimés on a laissé les
plus fragiles ce qui demandait le moins
des impôts des indépendances on les a
mis au pouvoir c'est-à-dire les plus
faibles parmi nous on les a mis au
pouvoir pour pouvoir mieux les contrôler
mieux exploiter l'Afrique mieux tuer les
Africains d'ailleurs parce que
aujourd'hui nous sommes pris entre ces
organisations mondiales dont vous parlez
qui qui nous exploite mais aussi par ça
dépend des pays d'ailleurs en Afrique
centrale par nos propres dictateurs nos
propres frères qui nous mettent dans une
situation difficile vous savez que
depuis les ajustements structuels
je voulais juste une première impression
et vous aurez l'occasion de détailler
les différents points madame Traoré une
première impression sur cette question
là ce mal développement malgré les
atouts une première impression voilà
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
mais moi je doute
je me pose des questions sur ce que
ce développement veut dire quand vous
dites que
l'Afrique est dans la mondialisation au
même titre que les autres
et que il y a
j'entends parler dans certaines membres
d'indicateurs l'idée de toute façon que
et la mondialisation est à marcher et
aurait tiré en tout cas pour ceux qui
concernent le sud global
bon nombre de gens de la pauvreté et
ainsi de suite
soyons réalistes prenons le cours
du monde au moment où je vous parle d'où
vous me parlez et d'où je vous parle moi
j'ai l'intime conviction que la
mondialisation heureuse est une sorte de
chimère et que nous de toute façon et la
décolonisation est restée inachevée nous
sommes des pays sous tutelle
immédiatement après
l'accession en fait de ce que nous nous
avons cru être et des indépendances et
on a on est on est entré on a emboîté le
parc en fait on n'a pas su rompre avec
un système et économique
destructeur prédateurs liés à la nature
du système global donc vous increminez
le système global vous en pensez quoi
Sylvie Brunel
cette image peut déconsidérer de
l'Afrique pour malgré les atouts et le
développement
en fait et certains c'est que les
marchands les militaires et les
missionnaires qui font des la
colonisation de l'Afrique sont toujours
présents à l'oeuvre dans les Afrique ils
prennent d'autres formes mais ce sont
toujours des marchands des militaires et
des missionnaires
omniprésents dans les 54 pays d'Afrique
et puis quand on regarde
continuum colonial oui mais il a changé
de nature c'est-à-dire que les
profiteurs de l'Afrique sont aujourd'hui
extrêmement nombreux à l'extérieur et à
l'intérieur c'est ça le comble c'est à
dire que ce continent qui est formé de
force vives extrêmement marquantes et
qui pourrait apprendre au reste du monde
ce qu'est le développement durable ce
qu'est la résilience ce qu'est
l'économie de l'ensemble des matières la
relation avec la nature le cette
vitalité et bien ce continent continue
d'être en que des indicateurs de
développement et moi j'en veux pour
preuve quelque chose qui me marque et le
taux de mortalité infantile le taux de
mortalité infantiste est un bon
révélateur de la situation d'un pays
c'est le nombre des enfants qui meurent
avant l'âge d'un an pour 1000 naissances
vivantes la moyenne mondiale est de 28
pour mille elle a beaucoup baissé on est
vraiment dans une dans une évolution qui
est très très encourageante mais en
Afrique c'est toujours presque le double
c'est-à-dire que le continent africain
c'était un continent riche peuplé de
pauvres qui se battent au quotidien pour
leur survie avec des dirigeants qui ne
font pas toujours ce qu'il faudrait pour
aider leur peuple vous Antoine Glaser
un peu mais je pense que c'est surtout
une sorte de
substitution je veux dire en dehors
effectivement de certains nombres
d'acteurs sont toujours présents mais ce
qui m'a vraiment surpris moi j'ai bien
sûr j'ai plus connu la période
post-coloniale et c'est à quel point
finalement des personnalités dans tous
leurs secteurs et moi-même moi je me
considère comme un profiteur de
l'Afrique moi en tant que journaliste
spécialiste de l'Afrique j'ai pu pendant
30 ans comme ça écrire des livres faire
des bouquins parce que les une petite
publication que je faisais avait un
retentissement parce que mes confrères
africains soient français d'origine
africaine n'était pas pris au sérieux en
France soit ils étaient sous la pression
des autocrates dans leur pays donc je
veux dire moi je mène devant ma porte
seulement j'ai connu la substitution ça
a été l'enseignement tout le domaine de
l'enseignement pendant 30 ans c'était
des dizaines de milliers de Français qui
faisaient la coopération alors je ne
critique pas leur travail ce qu'ils ont
fait autre mais j'ai vu des rapports
confidentiels de ministère de la
Coopération en 89 90 encore ils ont dit
faut arrêter arrêtons parce que là il y
a sur 5000 coopérants il y en a 70 qui
sont des enseignants qui font à la place
des Africains donc je crois que si on ne
comprend pas un qu'il faut arrêter de se
substituer aux abstraits constamment pas
simplement leur donner son mais faire à
leur place ça c'est une première chose
et puis la deuxième chose c'est vrai
qu'à un certain moment donné voilà il
faut il faut comprendre qu'il y a une
période où il faut arrêter de faire à la
place de la deuxième quelque chose à
prendre de l'Afrique on n'a pas appris
de l'Afrique on a exporté dans tous nos
pays pas simplement d'une constitution
et pas simplement notre langue notre
façon de faire Aminata Traoré je
voudrais vous poser une question qui
peut paraître provocante et délicate
mais j'aimerais avoir votre avis
l'Afrique
se veut de plein pied dans le monde elle
est même si cela vous dit que la
mondialisation est malheureuse elle est
quand même pleinement active parce que
c'est une forte population avec des
ressources une activité mais elle est
toujours à la recherche d'une aide au
développement la question que je vous
pose et c'est à vous que je la pose
parce que vous avez exercer des
responsabilités politiques comment on
peut assumer un destin souverainement
tout en restant dépendant du reste du
monde
d'abord je voudrais que l'on est
distinction entre et profiteur de
l'extérieur et profiteur de l'intérieur
et je crois que pour il faut inscrire
l'Afrique dans le monde et il y a pas il
y a des spécificités et africaines nous
avons cette histoire singulière pour des
raisons que Calix a évoqué
mais moi je me dis que et les
responsabilités je peux pas dire que FMI
Banque mondiale
toutes ces institutions
financière monétaire et qui se des
relations de dominant à dominer ça a
toujours été ça et le de la traite
négrière à ce jour le système
capitaliste a toujours eu besoin de
richesses du continent en homme les
esclaves se ressource les ressources
naturelles rien n'a changé quand je
regarde je réfléchis je peux regarder ce
matin la situation de la dette africaine
nous nous sommes endettés pourquoi en
mettant en place des infrastructures
dont les grandes entreprises étrangères
avaient besoin et ont besoin et on
rembourse aujourd'hui et
moi vous me dites j'ai été au pouvoir
bon j'ai été ministre de la Culture je
sais de près que et l'Afrique n'a pas eu
que des dictateurs que des corrompus et
les dirigeants n'ont pas de masse de
manœuvre parce que les décisions se
prennent ailleurs et ça c'est pas
spécifique à l'Afrique j'ai fait le va
et bien
madame Traoré sur la question de la
dépendance est-ce que il y a pas un
problème de d'être à la fois dépendant
et de vouloir être souverain c'est quand
même les gens s'interrogent à ce sujet
là
mais non mais l'Afrique n'a pas choisi
d'être dépendant on a créé cette
dépendance quand et nous sommes et à la
sortie de ce que nous avons cru échapper
au jour colonial qu'est-ce que nous
avons fait nous avons continué les mêmes
cultures de rente
ce que Samira Mina appelle l'échange
inégal et a prévalu et continue nous
nous n'avons pas nous décidons pas des
prix des matières premières et quand on
connaît le processus de l'endettement on
a été je ne dis pas je ne suis pas dans
la victimisation mais c'est clair que et
le fardeau de la dette la manière dont
est le commerce mondial est structuré et
gérer et c'est un système de pillage de
l'Afrique et pas du fait des Africains
c'est pas le choix des Africains alors
pour poursuivre le débat j'aimerais
avoir votre avis l'Afrique ce sont des
Afrique et de nombreux pays africain
comment expliquer que certains se
débrouillent mieux que d'autres à la
fois au niveau de l'éducation
du système de santé voire du produit
national brut comment vous expliquez
cette différence entre les économies et
les sociétés en Afrique avant de
reprendre à votre question je voudrais
revenir sur quelque chose vous avez
parlé beaucoup de dépendance de
l'Afrique mais aujourd'hui nous sommes
tous
interdépendants l'Afrique dépend de
l'Occident qui dépend de l'Afrique qui
dépend de l'Asie je vais dire nous
sommes interconnectés à des degrés
divers mais aujourd'hui il y a personne
qui est totalement autonome je pense
qu'il faut arrêter non non vous allez me
laisser développement ne concerne pas
tous les pays l'aide au développement
vous pouvez récupérer votre aide au
développement vous renvoyez de l'aide à
des dictateurs qui vous les renvoient et
vous dites que vous aidez les africains
mais personne ne nous aide je quitte
d'abord à le signaler deuxième chose la
jeunesse africaine est devenue très
digne elle n'est pas là en train de
commander même s'il y a quelques gamins
qui traversent la messe pour survivre
l'Afrique n'a jamais ôté aussi digne
qu'à l'heure actuelle je tiens vraiment
à le dire nous ne sommes pas des
mendiants et la jeunesse africaine a
conscience aujourd'hui qu'elle est
qu'elle a des matières premières qu'elle
est riche qu'elle peut se développer
nous sommes sur un autre fait une autre
pour un autre schéma d'accord
je vais vous répondre à votre question
Pourquoi certains pays sont plus avant
ce que d'autres parce qu'ils ont eu des
meilleurs dirigeants et ils ont eu des
meilleurs dirigeants notamment au Ghana
avec les Rawlings qui ont quand même
éliminer tous les on a beau dire ce
qu'on veut tous les corrompus et qui ont
permis qu'avec le peu malgré ce que la
banque les banques mondiales et FMI
faisait servait à à éduquer leur peuple
et aller à l'aise scolariser et à les
soigner il y a eu par exemple en Afrique
centrale on a eu des bouffons il faut
quand même se dire la vérité au Cameroun
au Gabon on a eu ou en Centrafrique on a
eu des Sanguinaires des gens qui ont été
là qui pillaient tout qui voulaient tout
qui qui n'ont pas ce qui sont pas soucis
de leur peuple il y a cette
responsabilité aussi qu'elle a moi je ne
suis pas toujours en train de dire oui
mais la responsabilité est toujours
ailleurs je veux dire que quelquefois on
peut nourrir sa famille avec peu on peut
avoir le sens du partage et beaucoup
d'Africains aussi ont été comme leur
maître européen non pas eu le sens de de
du partage de vivre ensemble de donner
un peu à l'autre et il y a une
responsabilité partagée moi au fil des
années quand j'avance dans la vie je
trouve que il y a pas quelqu'un qui
ressemble plus à un autre qu'un autre
homme quel que soit sa couleur il se
ressemble les capitalistes les pilleurs
dans le monde franchement j'ai trop
vieilli pour penser qu'ils sont d'un
côté et pas de l'autre merci alors
Antoine Glaser qui avait crapahuté si je
puis dire dans beaucoup de pays
africains et depuis si longtemps comment
vous expliquez vous cette différence de
niveau économique entre les pays
africains
toujours obligé de parler de la
diversité vous avez un certain nombre de
pays qui ont mené des mouvements de
libération je veux dire que ça soit
l'Afrique du Sud de l'Algérie et autres
bon il me demande il ne demande pas
avoir des cadres de l'extérieur ça c'est
ou alors il y a une aide mais c'est
vraiment différent que des pays
convaincu vraiment dans une période dans
un cocon post-colonial pour faire court
qu'on appelle la France Afrique donc
c'est encore une fois c'est là pour moi
avec le recul c'est vraiment ce truc de
faire à la place des Africains de pas
laisser finalement pendant très
longtemps très honnête on parle
actuellement beaucoup des changements
Emmanuel Macron des nouvelles stratégies
africaines vis-à-vis de l'armée qui a
été
au Mali et au Burkina Faso mais pendant
des années moi j'ai connu pendant 30 ans
et ça pas simplement parce que la France
voulait parce que les chefs d'État
préféré pendant des années que les
l'armée française ne forment pas leurs
propres militaires parce qu'ils
craignaient les coups d'État et du coup
très bien voilà
les profits
entre les différents pays comment vous
avez un pays comme le Gabon ou va se
rendre Emmanuel Macron il y a un million
d'habitants vous ayez il y a des
richesses absolument incroyables il y a
eu de l'uranium maintenant il y a encore
du manganèse du pétrole et autres je
vais dire si c'était bien géré ça
devrait poser aucun problème
c'est-à-dire faut il faut vous pouvez
pas comparer ça avec le Nigéria qui est
en train de faire des élections tout à
fait peut-être pas honnêtes mais ils
font des ils font quand même des il y a
une vraie démocratie avec des élections
il y a 200 millions d'habitants il y en
aura 400 millions en 2050 ça sera vous
rendez compte qu'il y aura vraiment un
habitant sur terre sur quatre qui on
peut pas comparer la seule chose qu'il
faut quand même toujours se rappeler
c'est que c'est vraiment le moment
est-ce que voilà c'est c'est aux
Africains c'est vraiment quand on dit
Afrique des Africains c'est pas un mot
on va pas continuer à faire à leur place
qui se démerde vous avez vu tout le
monde vous l'avez dit vous l'avez dit
Sylvie Brunel j'aimerais avoir votre
avis à partir de ce qui a été dit là de
ce qui a été dit de cette différence de
développement est-ce qu'il vous paraît
illusoire qu'un jour y est un marché
économique une union africaine mais qui
fonctionne en corrigeant toutes ces
inégalités tant au niveau des ressources
que de démocratie est-ce qu'il y a il y
a quelque chose là qui empêche que cette
harmonie africaine vous savez dans les
années 60 on entendait que l'Asie ne
pourrait pas se développer on entendait
que les basculer dans la famille moi je
me souviens encore quand j'enseignais
dans mes jeunes années
l'un des la Chine c'était vraiment ce
qu'on appelle les PMA les pays les moins
avancés et aujourd'hui on nous parle de
la puissance chinoise qui est en train
de de rivaliser que la puissance
américaine en réalité quand on regarde
le continent africain on se rend compte
que c'est un vieux socle géologique qui
présente l'intérêt d'avoir aujourd'hui à
peu près toutes les ressources dont le
monde a besoin pour entamer ce qu'on
appelle la nouvelle révolution digitale
c'est vraiment le continent le plus
avancé à la fois dans sa gestion de de
l'économie dans sa gestion de des
ressources naturelles on sait bien que
les paysans africains sont une stratégie
de minimisation des risques on sait bien
à quel point ils ont depuis très
longtemps mis au point des systèmes pour
essayer de faire face aux aléas mais le
continent africain aujourd'hui ce dont
il souffre mais c'est aussi un atout
c'est que la moitié de la population a
moins de 15 ans quand vous êtes comment
voulez-vous gérer un pays où la moitié
de la population a moins de 15 ans et en
plus quand vous formez ces jeunes et
bien ils partent c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
vous formez des gens extrêmement
compétents qui deviennent médecins
ingénieurs à Grenoble dans le reste du
monde parce qu'on appelle l'exode des
cerveaux donc on a aujourd'hui une sorte
de comment dire de recul qui font qui
fait qu'on a l'impression que l'Afrique
est très difficile à développer en
réalité ma conviction c'est que dans 30
ans on regardera ça en disant mais quand
on pense que cette Afrique on pensait
qu'elle ne se développerait jamais alors
qu'en réalité qu'il s'agisse des
personnes âgées qui sont prises en
charge en Afrique qui ne sont pas livrés
le même qu'il s'agisse des mécanismes de
solidarité qu'il s'agisse des mécanismes
de résistance et de résilience face aux
chocs climatiques qu'il s'agisse de la
capacité à adopter très vite
l'innovation dans ce qu'on appelle le
saut de grenouille on a l'impression
qu'il suffit effectivement qui a un
déclic qu'on voit dans certains pays
parce qu'il y a certains pays
aujourd'hui qui sont très avancés très
très av malheureusement ce sont plutôt
des pays où les dictats les dirigeants
sont un peu autoritaires mais nous avons
aussi des démocraties très avancées pour
moi le jour où l'Afrique apprendra à
gérer intelligemment tous ces gens qui
veulent comment dire tirer parti de ces
richesses en faisant jouer les
concurrents et les convoitises chinoises
indiennes turques israélienne française
anglaise américaine comme le font
d'ailleurs déjà certains pays elle
deviendra la première puissance mondiale
parce qu'elle aura à la fois la jeunesse
la démographie les matières premières et
la capacité à gérer la nature
[Musique]
des questions de sécurité et stratégique
avec vous Antoine Glazer la France
poursuit son désengagement militaire de
l'Afrique
des puissances émergentes si installent
et se P en ressources minières et autres
prédations foncières qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de ces nouveaux profiteurs alors
les nouveaux profiteurs on pense bien
évidemment russe de Wagner ou autre
c'est bien évident qu'il y a des
profiteurs mais y profitent sur un
système c'est à dire il sera pas eux qui
créent c'est les problèmes ils profitent
d'un système ancien ça veut dire c'est
une sorte d'anachronisme historique ils
vont être là dans des secteurs ou par
exemple moi je pense que la France a eu
tort de se retirer de la Centrafrique
avec l'opération sanguaris parce que ils
ont sous-estimé à petit point par
exemple que la Centrafrique était un
pays totalement
géostratégique contenu de ces frontières
et compte tenu du fait que c'est un pays
quand il y a des diamants ça veut dire
Wagner il se paye sur les diamants en
particulier et une poignée de diamant là
si vous avez copains que vous allez voir
la 2 bière à Londres prenez une poésie
diamants vous avez 100 millions de
dollars dans votre dans votre main avec
ça vous faut évidemment que Wagner ils
peuvent se payer des mercenaires et la
France a laissé tomber la Centrafrique à
quel point que les Américains maintenant
c'est eux qui veulent venir chasser les
Russes de Centrafrique sauf que la
France a été chassée effectivement de sa
haine mais à mon avis c'était une
période historique qui se passait aux
ancienne période des coloniale on était
beaucoup trop présent pendant une
période beaucoup trop longue donc je
veux dire on s'éteint c'est l'histoire
qui parle et il faut vraiment penser que
ce continent est devenu l'Afrique c'est
mondialisée sans qu'on s'en rende compte
à Paris on avait l'impression de
regarder la réunification de l'Allemagne
et on voyait pas du tout l'Afrique ce
mondialisée moi je me souviens une vieux
patronaux les mecs disaient la Chine
écoute arrêtez de nous emmerder les
chinois ils ont besoin de nous etc donc
on est c'est une période historique et
très honnêtement ce continent il faut
faire confiance aux gens qui sont qui
sont à la manœuvre alors si il y a des
autocrates il se débrouillent les Russes
franchement ils servent sur des
situations anciennes sur les
anachronismes historiques sur le
refouler mais je veux dire il faut
parler de l'histoire de cette période
particulière
il s'agit pas de d'avoir des questions
qui fâchent mais il s'agit d'avancer bon
on parle de profiteur et c'est le thème
de l'émission ma Russie la Chine Turquie
plein de pays sont là et sont là pour
leur propre intérêts comme l'été la
France Afrique à votre avis
l'expérience que vous avez de l'Afrique
suffit-elle à empêcher ces nouveaux
profiteurs de piller l'Afrique
et qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
pour ne pas les laisser
libre de cette prédation parce que tous
les pays sont prédateurs il y a pas que
l'Europe dans ce domaine-là je pense que
vous sous-estimez beaucoup les Africains
ça me gêne vraiment ça me gêne parce que
nous sommes des êtres humains nous avons
une expérience de la prédation on ne va
pas quitter la France Afrique pour
tomber dans les mains des Russes
d'accord vous pensez que on est là parce
qu'on nous les adorons on les connaît
même pas moi je parle pas le russe il y
a peut-être quelques africains qui
parlent le russe on les connaît pas mais
on a eu besoin de pour des situations
bien précises de terrorisme mais vous
pensez qu'on va les laisser là mais vous
vous courrez aucun Africain ne va
laisser on ne va plus laisser quelqu'un
rester là et nous piller mais on ne va
pas non plus se couper du reste du monde
on aura toujours des partenaires dont
les russes dont les Français dans les
Américains
des gens brillants qui partent tous les
gens brillants ne partent pas
0,2% seulement d'Africains quitte le
continent la plupart de l'immigration
africaine se fait à l'intérieur de ce
continent
et les médecins c'est camerounais vont
vous donner la Gabon plus qu'en France
même si si ils vont travailler au Gabon
où ils seront mieux payés ils vont
travailler en Afrique du Sud en fait
l'immigration africaine est d'abord
inter-africaine je veux dire en même
temps les hommes se sont toujours
déplacés il y a aussi des médecins
français en Afrique aux États-Unis je
veux dire vous n'allez pas empêcher le
monde d'être le monde c'est-à-dire que
des hommes seront contre comme depuis la
nuit des temps qu'ils échangent des
idées qu'ils échangent des expériences a
toujours été comme ça merci alors Sylvie
Brunel il faut qu'on avance un peu dans
cette émission il y a une question
économique qui se pose
on considère que les ajustements
structurels vous pourrez même expliquer
ce que ça veut dire du FMI de la Banque
mondiale
de l'OMC etc on provoqué des faillites
socio-économiques pas simplement
d'Afrique on l'a vu aussi en Amérique
latine est-ce que vous considérez que
c'est encore vrai aujourd'hui alors il
faudrait rappeler très très rapidement
que l'Afrique est entrée dans la crise
de la dette dans les années
1980-1990 qu'à la suite de cela elle a
vu des coortes de d'experts
internationaux lui prendre comment dire
sa souveraineté pour appliquer ce que
vous ce qu'on appelle des programmes
d'ajustement sur structurel c'est à dire
libéralisation ouverture des frontières
privatisation des entreprises publiques
parallèlement à cette ingérence
économique il y a eu une ingérence
politique puisqu'on a conditionné l'aide
à la démocratisation sachant qu'un
certain nombre de chefs d'État tenaient
leur légitimité de leur soutien
extérieur que ces soutiens viennent du
monde
occidental ou du monde soviétique dans
les années 1990-2000 l'Afrique est
entrée dans ce que j'appelle dans le
livre la décennie du chaos c'est-à-dire
que cette ces deux chocs extrêmement
brutaux ont provoqué un grand nombre de
guerres civiles 35 pays en guerre sur 53
puisque le Soudan du Sud n'existait pas
encore face auquel nous avons répondu
d'abord par de l'humanitaire dans une
logique de container à l'époque
l'histoire mais aujourd'hui mais vous
savez bien aimer que pour comprendre
aujourd'hui faut mettre un petit peu le
nez dans l'histoire ensuite l'Afrique
est entrée dans une forte période de
croissance qui était la période 2000
2010 à peu près il y a eu vous le savez
en Occident la crise des subprimes et la
pensée qu'elle en serait excluée elle en
a subi le rebond ce qui a provoqué un
certain nombre de crises ensuite il y a
eu de 2010 à 20 bien ce qu'on pourrait
appeler la période chinoise avec une
Chine extrêmement présente en Afrique
investissant beaucoup et puis des
process d'annulation de dettes aussi de
la part des Européens et des enfin des
Occidentaux se rendant compte que
finalement ils avaient placé les
Africains dans des conditions dans
lesquelles dont ils ne pouvaient pas
sortir et ensuite il y a eu la pandémie
de covid cette pandémie de covid elle a
eu quelque chose de très surprenant
c'est qu'on s'est rendu compte que
l'Afrique manifestait une résilience
extraordinaire le reste du monde tombait
dans une espèce d'hécatombe et on voyait
que l'Afrique elle est résistait d'abord
parce que sa population
aujourd'hui mais pour comprendre mon
diagnostic aujourd'hui mon diagnostic
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il n'y a jamais eu
autant d'acteurs étrangers qui
s'intéressent à l'Afrique mais qu'il n'y
a jamais eu autant aussi d'opportunités
comme la décalixte pour les Africains de
jouer de ces rivalités de ses
concurrents pour tirer leur épingle du
jeu sachant que c'est eux qui possèdent
aujourd'hui
les richesses que le monde entier
convoite pour pouvoir réussir la
transition écologique ils ont toutes ces
richesses il s'agit juste qu'ils ont
reprennent comment la souveraineté
j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur cette
question des institutions
financières internationale le FMI la
Banque mondiale est-ce que vous
considérez que ces institutions
aujourd'hui encore aujourd'hui
empêche j'allais dire des situations
harmonieuses en Afrique
oui bien sûr et moi je ne suis pas sûr
comme Sylvie
Brunel
le soutien que
les choses vont si bien dans certains
pays
là la question fondamentale ce que
développe veut dire qu'est-ce que
développer veut dire est-ce que c'est
les infrastructures des bâtiments qui
poussent des investisseurs étrangers qui
viennent je n'en suis pas sûr et
nos pays nos États ont les mêmes maîtres
ils ont les mêmes maîtres FMI Banque
mondiale et OMC l'Union européenne ce
sont les mêmes
et nous nous inscrivons nous l'Afrique
aujourd'hui et s'inscrit et dans une
dynamique mondiale qui relève de la
guerre
la mondialisation néolibérale c'est de
la guerre c'est une guerre sans merci
c'est elle aujourd'hui qui est
aujourd'hui et la guerre Russo
ukrainienne l'OTAN nous ne sommes
l'Afrique ne fonctionne pas en dehors de
ces réalités le temps s'occupe
aujourd'hui du Sahel pourquoi
et pour qu'on s'y tonne que au début de
cette guerre il y a 10 ans quand je dis
que c'était pas notre guerre aujourd'hui
j'entends les Africains disent ce n'est
pas notre guerre je fais partie de ceux
qui dès 2013 en 17 guerre soit disant
antivialiste n'est pas notre guerre les
djihadistes que je connais que je vois
aujourd'hui qui sème la terreur et dans
le village qui qui tue sont des victimes
des programmes d'ajustement sur lequel
on peut pas me dire que c'est fini que
c'était une autre histoire c'est la même
histoire mais sous et qu'est-ce qu'ils
font qu'est-ce qui se passe
souvenez-vous la grande et et disons
quand la Banque mondiale ne jurait que
par la lutte contre les pauvreté
elle est devenue aujourd'hui l'accès
elle c'est vite transformée en une lutte
contre les pauvres parce que les projets
mis en oeuvre profitaient d'abord à
d'autres à une poignée d'africaine ce
sont qui sont
économique c'est pas la relation de
mettre à esclave d'il y a plusieurs
siècles vous pour les pays sont
indépendants aujourd'hui alors
les mêmes et j'ai entendu dire dans le
cadre de l'intervention militaire de la
France au Mali que c'est un devoir de
civilisation et c'est ce que j'entends
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de la guerre
Russo ukrainien ou bien plutôt de la
l'Occident contre la Russie vice versa
j'en sais rien ce que je sais c'est que
les rien n'a changé et c'est notre
grille de lecture c'est le diagnostic
qui me paraît aujourd'hui totalement
erroné vous pouvez comprendre l'Afrique
s'il vous plaît
et dans cette levée de bouclier des
peuples du monde il n'y a pas qu'ici il
est peuples du monde aujourd'hui disent
NON et à la dictature du marché je crois
Kalix intervenir sur la question des
institutions financières par rapport à
ce qui a été dit ben écoutez j'épouse
tout ce qui a été dit par rapport aux
institutions financières n'étant pas
économiste c'est vrai que je me souviens
de cet ajustement structurel qui avait
mis le Cameroun chaos mes oncles sont
retrouvés au chômage je devais me
débrouiller chez toute seule à Paris
pour leur envoyer de quoi le manger mais
sachez aussi que au-delà de l'infirmier
tout ça les gouvernements notamment du
Cameroun vont profiter de la justement
structurelle pour dominer les
populations comment à savoir que ces
ajustements structurels ont pris fin
dans les années 2000 d'accord au
Cameroun le salaire avait été divisé par
3 aujourd'hui alors que la plupart des
pays ont remis les salaires en place le
Cameroun l'a pas fait ce qui veut dire
que on a un salaire trois fois moindre
que par exemple au Gabon ou en
Centrafrique et dans d'autres pays
africains c'est fait exprès pour mieux
écraser les peuples pour mieux les
dominer mais comment vous pouvez dire
des choses pareilles c'est la vérité
quand on voit que ces 50 dernières
années
l'Afrique a considérablement progressé
en espérance de vie en politique
d'éducation de santé etc est-ce que
c'est pas est-ce que c'est pas exagéré
que de dire que c'est ces institutions
sont venues écraser vous oubliez aussi
une chose c'est la capacité
d'inventivité de créativité du peuple
africain nous avons nous-même avec nos
petits moyens construit des petites
écoles dans les villages construit des
petites dispensaires remis en place les
méthodes traditionnelles de soins
c'est-à-dire que notre pharmacopée
aujourd'hui est plus valide que jamais
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de la
covid 19 nous n'avons pas attendu les
vaccins pour soigner nos mains là de
covid on a récupéré nos médicaments
traditionnels nous nous sommes soignés
avec j'y étais donc
tout ce qui était méprisé autrefois a
été réhabilité dans nos pensées pas que
nous sommes là
qu'on nous apporte ce qu'il faut en bâti
nos universités aujourd'hui des
universités panafricaines avec d'autres
modes de réflexion d'autres façons de
d'enseigner aussi dans un pays comme le
Cameroun c'est un peuple extrêmement
dynamique qui crée des universités on
attend pas les aides on en a pas besoin
parce qu'on sait que quelquefois c'est
un poison et que souvent c'était une
manière de nous intégrer et de nous
dominer nous en sommes conscients moi je
suis une enfant d'après les
indépendances ce n'est pas pareil que
nos parents qui sont nés avant les
indépendances on a une autre façon de
regarder le monde nous faisons partie du
monde et ce monde nous allons le
conquérir je suis très confiante sur le
fait que dans 30 ans comme disait Sylvie
notre pays notre continent sera la terre
d'accueil de tous les autres peuples du
monde Antoine Glaser
votre point de vue sur cette question
des institutions
c'est vrai que on a beaucoup critiqué le
FMI la Banque mondiale quand des pays
sont en difficulté ils exigent des
ajustements qui ont des conséquences
mais vous avez le sentiment que tout ce
qui a été distribué comme aide au
développement à travers ces institutions
n'a eu que des effets négatifs je suis
incapable de me prononcer sur le fond je
suis pas économiste simplement ce que je
peux dire c'est que la même façon que la
France a exporté dans ces pays ces
institutions etc etc ce qui permet que
les chefs d'État d'ailleurs ils sont
devenus des vrais constitutionnalistes
et leur permet de faire des deuxième et
troisième quatrième mandat mais surtout
ce que je crois par contre c'est que ces
grandes institutions Brighton Woods
effet mi Bank mondiale ça leur a permis
de faire vivre des dizaines de milliers
d'experts pourquoi parce que ils
envoyaient avec les prêts d'ajustement
structurels autour de ce qui était
proposer une façon d'une autre il y a
bien évidemment des dédiés mais vraiment
je me suis connu dans les hôtels il y a
les hôtels en Afrique qui étaient
bourrés d'experts pourquoi c'était comme
si c'était une autre langue le FMI la
Banque mondiale c'était la bonne c'était
vraiment la langue des économistes que
les Africains fallait surtout pas leur
apprendre cette langue et ça faisait
c'est des experts qui avaient été autour
des conseillers autour de tous les
ministres etc c'est ça la domination
aussi donc moi je me prononce pas je
sais pas si c'est prêt ce qu'ils ont
apporté ce qu'ils ont retiré mais je
peux vous dire qu'il y a des il y a des
livres vraiment ça fait vivre
l'extérieur c'est la même chose on va en
parler sur sans doute avec Sylvie sur
les ONG pourquoi est-ce que par exemple
de l'extérieur on donne jamais à des ONG
locales on donne toujours à des ONG de
l'extérieur alors souvent je vais pas
citer l'agence ou d'autres qui me disent
toujours ah oui mais on peut pas parce
que nous on est banquier en tant que
banquier on peut pas donner à une gé
locale et tout ça c'est ça qui crée
aussi ce sentiment de dépossession de
l'Afrique par rapport à ces grandes
institutions
de jeunes africains il y a des
financières on parle de ces grandes
institutions Sylvie Brunel mais
certaines ONG sont en elles-mêmes de
grandes institutions pour ne pas les
citer par exemple Oxfam à des moyens
considérables quelle bilan vous faites
de cette action des ONG disons des
principales ONG
en Afrique le bilan il est contrasté il
est positif il est vous savez Émilie un
proverbe en Afrique qui dit la main qui
donne est toujours au-dessus de la main
qui reçoit et vous avez donc une
prolifération d'institutions qui
prétendent tous sauver l'Afrique malgré
elle vous savez que le développement
c'est avoir la capacité de choix
c'est-à-dire être souverain quand on est
face à son destin or qu'est-ce qu'on
constate on constate que dans le domaine
de l'humanitaire aujourd'hui tout un
ensemble d'acteurs prétendent à leur
niveau savoir mieux que le paysan
africain ce qui est bon pour son avenir
on constate que dans l'environnement et
Calixte qui a fait allusion on crée
aujourd'hui des zones protégées et
protégées contre l'éleveur africain
contre le paysan africain avec la
complexité la complicité des autorités
locales on constate aussi que chaque
fois que l'on reçoit un prêt alors vous
savez que l'Europe a largement
aujourd'hui annuler sa dette et délier
son aide c'est à dire que elle ne
conditionne plus son aide à l'achat de
bien et de services en provenance de
l'Europe mais ce n'est pas du tout le
cas de la Chine qui est d'une façon
beaucoup plus cynique et qui exige pour
pouvoir construire des infrastructures
avoir accès aux ports mettre en place
des mécanismes de coopération d'avoir la
main mise sur les matières premières
africaines qui créent aussi des systèmes
complètement fermés où elles n'emploie
pas les Africains il y a très peu par
exemple de mariage qu'on pourrait
appeler inter ratio même si cette
formule ne veut rien dire donc on se
rend compte que effectivement l'Afrique
est envahie d'acteurs aux motivations
plus ou moins troubles qu'elle a
beaucoup de mal à coordonner qu'elle a
beaucoup de mal surtout à dominer si je
puis dire c'est à dire dont elle a
beaucoup de mal et je pense qu'il faut
qu'elle reprenne dans ce domaine sa
souveraineté pour ça il ne faut plus
qu'elle demande d'aide de l'extérieur
parce qu'elle a elle-même les moyens sur
place avec toutes ces matières premières
avec tous ces atouts de transformer sur
place en créant un marché intérieur un
processus de développement qui la
rendrait comme les pays d'Asie comme la
Chine comme les émergents d'Asie de
l'est totalement souveraine quant à son
avenir et c'est en cela que je pense
pour revenir à ce que disait Calixte
tout à l'heure que on peut très bien
avoir dans 30 ans à renversement total
de l'histoire de l'humanité avec une
Afrique ou un Afrique un humain sur
quatre sera effectivement africain et
qui donnera le la au reste du monde sur
la gestion des personnes âgées sur la
gestion de la nature sur la gestion de
l'énergie sur la gestion aussi de ce
qu'est un développement qui sait saisir
le meilleur des technologies je vous ai
entendu alors puisqu'on est bientôt à la
fin de cette émission et qu'on parle de
grandes transformations madame Traoré
vous êtes avec nous là depuis Bamako je
voudrais vous poser une question qui
fait partie de vos préoccupations
politiques
au niveau de l'écologie la prise de
conscience du réchauffement climatique
elle est acquise partout
en Afrique comme ailleurs les politiques
économiques ne suivent pas toujours
notamment en matière de coopération de
commerces extérieures de transition
énergétique qu'est-ce qui empêche à
votre avis l'Afrique d'avoir aujourd'hui
une politique écologique
qui tiennent contre à la fois des
traditions et de la modernité
c'est pour ça que je
m'interroge encore une fois si dans j'ai
l'impression le notre débat va dans le
sens de même si on idéalise pas le
développement c'est comme si il y a un
modèle performant et vertueux quelque
part l'Afrique n'y est pas et elle va
certainement y arriver comme les autres
mais moi je n'habite pas les autres
quand je regarde l'état du monde
aujourd'hui je n'envie pas les autres
c'est à nous à la lumière de
l'état catastrophique de la planète
c'est à nous
dit de dire de nous dire il prétend
l'avoir décollé ils sont partis mais
nous voici au même endroit quand je
regarde la bagarre pour les retraites et
les tremblements de terre les migrants
on a tellement de problèmes
qu'Alexandre raison de dire que tout ça
c'est humain on a devant nous et non une
somme considérable de situation qui ne
permet pas
d'être et optimiste en disant et on va y
arriver comme les autres mais j'ai pas
envie d'y arriver comme les autres parce
que les autres ils sont pas ils sont pas
précisément parce que le modèle le
modèle dont on parle c'est le même
modèle nous on n'a pas eu le temps de
penser d'avoir une pensée économique et
politique qui devait nous mettre à
l'abri de cette situation donc c'est
parce que les autres savent ceux qui
sont partis les sociétés et les nations
extravagistes colonialiste qui sont est
sortis par la fenêtre qui reviennent par
la
qui disent et les autres quand ils
parlent de la Russie de la Chine et de
la Turquie ils disent les compétiteurs
les concurrents ce qui veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que l'Afrique est une croix
l'Afrique est une proie donc les
gagnants de ce système ceux qui ont cru
qu'ils gagnaient se bousculent veulent
occuper le terrain pour que les autres
ne viennent pas et nous Africains
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on va être en train
de dire venez et venez il y a les terres
il y a les ressources et allons-y nous
voulons nous développer comme vous mais
moi j'ai pas envie de me développer
comme eux d'autant plus que notre
continent et il s'était on a un dépôt
toi
les déchets moi je ne vois que des
déchets je me suis battu toute ma vie
pour les textile africains mais quand je
regarde aujourd'hui je ne vois que la
friperie dans les partout de Nairobi à
Dakar la plupart des boutiques nos
jeunes ne vendent que des restes
en train de dire vous êtes en train de
dire que l'écologie est une chance pour
l'Afrique bien sûr elle pourrait être
une chance pour l'Afrique pourvu que ce
soit pas le modèle capitaliste
destructeur conscient littlement
destructeurs des humains de la cohésion
sociale et du vivant
ce qui n'empêche pas qu'il y ait du
capitalisme dans les pays africains
comme ailleurs un mot là-dessus et on a
terminé Calix Beyala oui non mais c'est
vrai que sur l'écologie comme une chance
l'Afrique n'a pas eu besoin du mot
écologique pour être écologiste le
peuple africain autrefois naturellement
ne prenait de la nature que ce dont il
avait besoin on ne connaît jamais plus
moi je me souviens quand j'étais enfant
de mes oncles quand ils allaient à la
chasse ils allaient ramener un gibier
pas parce qu'ils en avaient pas trouvé
10 ou 20 mais un ça dit selon et
d'ailleurs me demander le matin et bien
elle va s'engueuler m'appeler par montre
qu'est-ce que tu veux manger aujourd'hui
je disais ben je veux une biche voilà et
ils avaient une biche pour tout le
village mais pas 10 biche donc on a pas
eu besoin de l'Occident pour pouvoir
savoir ce qu'il faut faire pour vivre en
cohésion avec la nature ça c'est le
premier point de le deuxième point c'est
que effectivement comme le disait
on a eu nous sommes devenus un dépotoir
avec les vieilles voitures et les vieux
et les la fille prairie tout ce qui les
vieux frigo les vieilles télévisions
tout ce dont on n'a pas besoin ils
mettent ça dans les bateaux ils viennent
jeter ça chez nous et ça nous pollue
mais on n'est pas encore autant pour lui
donc nous allons faire un travail et moi
je suis confiante là-dessus pour balayer
tout cela réapprendre aux gens comme
nous parlons le faisait autrefois à
marcher à pied on oublie que nous on
faisait 20 km pour aller à l'école les
jeunes africains ont oublié ça on va
repartir vers un autre type de
développement ça veut pas dire qu'on va
rejeter ce qu'il y a de bon donc c'est
donc c'est pas ça on va prendre tout ce
que vous avez de bon et on va faire à
notre façon pour ne pas avoir ce que
vous avez produit de mal ça c'est la
chance que nous avons c'est pour ça que
je suis contre ceux qui disent il faut
rejeter totalement l'Occident ah non non
non et de très belles choses et nous
allons les prendre par exemple le
système de retraite moi je trouve ça
très bien et on va on va d'appliquer ou
les lois sur le travail il faudrait
peut-être qu'on s'inspire de ça et que
les travailleurs soient plus protégés la
sécurité sociale moi j'aimerais bien
qu'on ait ça chez nous je veux dire que
et mais il y a des choses que je ne
mérite pas le développement à tout prix
les immeubles partout parce que l'humain
n'a pas besoin de de temps de richesse
de tant d'argent pour survivre nous
allons refuser cet aspect là merci
écoutez les missions se terminent
là-dessus donc sur une Afrique qui
serait et qui est de comme vous l'avez
dit en phase avec ce développement
durable et contre tous les gaspillages
alors il me reste à vous présenter une
bibliographie
Aminata Traoré vous avez publié il y a
quelques années les taux ou l'Afrique
dans un monde sans frontières vous
n'avez pas changé d'avis aujourd'hui
non
vous pensez que les taux est toujours là
et qu'il se resserre mais on va se
battre avant bien écoutez alors je
voudrais signaler le livre
d'Eric Toussaint Banque Mondial une
histoire critique et que c'est un livre
qui est plein d'informations sur les
relations dont on a parlé entre
l'Afrique et les grandes institutions et
tous ces ajustements structurels qui ont
provoqué comme ça a été dit au cours de
cette émission de nombreux dégâts alors
Antoine Glaser vous avez publié il y a
quelques années avec Stephen Smith
l'Afrique sans africain
noir le rêve blanc du continent noir et
votre livre le piège africain de Macron
vient d'être publié chez pluriel qu'elle
continuité il y a entre tous ces livres
sur l'Afrique est-ce que
c'est une chez vous c'est quoi une
mission mais mais c'est vrai que quand
j'entends Aminata qui parle de d'Afrique
des potoirs c'est vrai que moi ça me
fait Moundir avant de s'occuper enfin je
vais pas être critique sur la de voyage
du président Macron en Gabon mais avant
de dire que les forêt grande forêts du
Gabon c'est vraiment les les forêts sont
les biens communs de l'humanité comme si
ça appartenait pas aux Africains c'est
les biens communs de tout le monde il
faut pas toucher à ses forêts qu'on
s'occupe déjà de l'Afrique des photos de
laser un mot quand même quand on dit que
les forêts sont des biens c'est dans la
mesure où il capture le gaz carbonique
c'est les biens communs de l'humanité ok
mais et à part ça l'Afrique finalement
et finalement elle a été très vertueux
par rapport à l'ensemble du monde sur la
pollution du monde et on va dire ah bah
faut toucher surtout pas vos forêts
parce que ça peut servir à tout le monde
ok mais là non mais c'est là où il y a
un vrai problème bien Calix Beyala vous
avez publié Il y a quelques années les
honneurs perdus vous voulez ou le Christ
selon l'Afrique le plus récent ou le
Christ dans l'Afrique
tout ça vous restez finalement dans ce
lignage africain pour quand vous écrivez
c'est l'Afrique qui écrit en vous au
finalement maintenant vous êtes comme
vous vivez également en France est-ce
que c'est le monde qui vous motive et à
l'Afrique me motive certes mais en même
temps j'appartiens au monde je vais dire
que moi je crois plus en l'identité
géographique des peuples qu'à l'identité
raciale c'est à dire vous prenez un
petit européen pour le mettez en Afrique
pour moi c'est un Africain parce que
l'environnement dans lequel il vit va
faire de lui ce qu'il est donc ce que je
suis c'est un mélange de l'Afrique et de
le et de l'Europe et personne ne peut me
le donner et mes enfants sont pareils et
chaque être humain aujourd'hui dépend de
son environnement et c'est pour ça que
ceux qui parlent de de grand
remplacement et tous ces conneries
j'appelle ça vraiment
émission donc ignorons puisque
ignorons cet extrémisme là alors ça fait
partie donc c'est pour dire tout
simplement nous sommes tous là à la fois
bien entendu Sylvie Brunel vous venez de
publier nourrir cessons de maltraiter
ceux qui nous font vivre nous aurons
l'occasion de parler des paysans de
l'agriculture mais pourquoi vous avez
publié ce cri aujourd'hui
parce que dans le monde entier on n'a
jamais autant parlé de l'arme
alimentaire de l'insécurité alimentaire
qu'il y a dans le monde entier plus
d'1,3 milliards de paysans qui
travaillent dur qui nous nourrissent et
que dans tous les pays ils sont méprisés
ils sont critiqués alors que tous les
enjeux aujourd'hui écologiques
énergétiques paysager patrimoniaux et
bien sûr nourricier passe par eux parce
qu'ils travaillent avec le vivant et
c'est particulièrement vrai sur le
continent africain où les mégalopoles
sont extrêmement importatrices de
nourriture alors qu'on a encore plus de
la moitié de la population qui travaille
dans les campagne donc vous considérez
aujourd'hui que l'alimentation est
sacrifiée au profit de la grosse
industrialisation et du capitalisme
international non c'est pas ça non je
considère que la souveraineté
alimentaire c'est une question
essentielle qui est revenue au premier
plan avec la pandémie la guerre en
Ukraine l'inflation le fait que les
exportations de la Russie et de
l'Ukraine ont été bloqués pendant très
longtemps alors que vous le savez la
Russie est aujourd'hui le premier
producteur de blé au monde et que nous
avons besoin aujourd'hui dans ce monde
de plus en plus urbain de reconsidérer
ces gens dans les campagnes qui triment
dur comme la décalix qui élève des bêtes
et qui ont sont souvent considéré comme
la dernière roue du carrosse merci donc
pour cet éloge mérité de la paysannerie
et du monde agricole il me reste à vous
remercier mesdames
chers Antoine Glaser
je voudrais remercier l'équipe de LCP
qui a permis donc la réalisation de
cette émission et avant de nous quitter
je vous laisse avec cette citation de
Nicolas Baverez l'Afrique a
considérablement changé depuis la fin du
20e siècle elle participe à la naissance
d'un Sud global
[Musique]